what is the next category now let's try
a special moment oh okay so i mean this
is going to be pretty
uh narrowed down i guess because there's
only been three
especially uh originally we had best
trash taste special and then we kind of
realized
there's only three specials there's not
really much to choose from
so let's narrow it down to the best
moments you enjoyed from the trash taste
specials all right
let's look at the nominees so what are
the nominees
two cars of course
eventually though i might have done a
small oopsie
your [ __ ] face is priceless because i
heard the [ __ ] clutch
i heard it from all the way up the top
like whoa what's the [ __ ]
died and i was like oh [ __ ] i i i
my favorite shot of this is when you
were just like i bet god's giggling away
at his car and i'm just [ __ ] losing
it in my own car
i know you too wow i remember
seeing you break it and i just i just i
just couldn't contain myself
i thought it was that was like the most
on-brand kind of thing that could ever
happen what can i say monkey brain
breaking
and then i was like all right we got the
dub and then connor's like finna break
another one
yeah yeah honestly and then next one is
god wins the chess tournament arc oh man
this is
i can't rewatch this was the biggest
upset it wasn't to play the clip play
the clip
oh
what an amazing moment what an amazing w
that was probably like top five best
moments of my life never threw so hard
in my life you know
i just played [ __ ] that was like this
this wasn't so much funny as much as it
was just like you couldn't script this
right if like i'm i'm surprised how well
the trash taste toilet arc
was just like came out like like it was
like an anime script yeah honestly
you know like all three of us got top
three you know
even though it's the most proud third
place i've ever taken in my life
and like biggest plot twist of the
entire arc
which is me coming out on top it's the
protagonist's pals man that's another
piece of the lord
the protagonist the protagonist's power
we have the protagonist we got the
antagonist
how do you feel about this connor not
good i'm good all right well this next
one is probably my favorite
gone cycling meltdown play the clue you
know what the [ __ ] lifting off things i
like
how about listing off things i hate joey
for being an australian [ __ ] who's
[ __ ] ahead of me right now
i love the classical music in the
background it's so very good it's very
fitting
i'm just like this moment would have
wouldn't have worked so well
if you didn't film yourself eating the
ice cream honestly
a hundred percent coincidence i didn't
even know it was recording we never
turned the cameras off that's why we
never took the camera's off exactly
honestly i think what this like this was
the most british moment of my life
um i don't think like i don't think
because
i don't think i've complained about
things more in my life than like this
exact moment because oh yeah definitely
this i was just dying
by this point i just i just needed to
let out some complaints man sorry
it got you through man it got me through
it got me through and then next one is
almost dying in the backseat of a drift
car to this day this is still this was
still terrifying
i love you guys
[Applause]
i just the g's felt insane yeah insanity
i just i still remember his like
maniacal laughs yeah he was i wish that
would got picked up more on it
yeah i kept [ __ ] laughing like he'd
be like drifting around the corner
pumping this handbrake and looking at it
like i've never seen anyone move a
handbrake like this in my life
like the adrenaline rush it's
not anything that i could ever describe
yeah right because the adrenaline rush
for that was
by far the biggest adrenaline rush i had
felt in my entire life
i can see how people get addicted to
adrenaline after doing that oh yeah i
wish i could drive that good
yeah right and said i break the cars i
was like is this handbrake even working
you're like moving it around so much
like
probably not doing anything and the
final moment the boys cheated cycling
my favorite those boys not me by the way
hey connor bye
hey connor oh are you there
you're [ __ ] oh it's so funny
all right let's find out the winner
though honestly [ __ ] man any of these
could win
these great moments just reliving these
moments it's just we
i like what i love about the specials is
that i have a [ __ ] great time
filming the specials you know and it's a
fantastic like trip down memory lane
right like this doesn't feel like six
months ago i thought the drifting one
was difficult
to film i was like that was hard to film
and then yeah the cycling i'm like oh no
this is hot oh yeah
yeah i'm i'm surprised how well the
cycling moment came out which like
[ __ ] mvp of the cycling special muda
i'm going through
100 hours of footage like 100 hours of
footage you're like
cameras six gopros which were constantly
filming yeah we did ask when hey mood on
here's a hundred hours of footage
turned it into one yeah it was like half
a terabyte video yeah
it was a lot it was a lot and there's
audio and stuff it was an absolutely
yeah i moved on to beast mvp mood on
yeah but they can only be one winner
unfortunately
who do you want to win games oh [ __ ] me
these are all so good i
personally want god's cycling meltdown i
think
because that just was hilarious i don't
know the editing was hilarious can't
guard you
i think you know objectively i enjoyed
the chess winning [ __ ] off moment
that better not most if that was like
this i'm not reading it
that's just that's just me i think um my
cycling meltdown is weird because
during filming i [ __ ] hated it but
like it was it was just like
the moment where i look at it and i'm
just like okay i'm glad my suffering
made for good content yeah exactly
exactly but let's find out who's
suffering made for the best content
in this award oh it's upside down it's
like this okay
[Music]
it's gone cycling meltdown hey well
deserve
walder's uh the worst
screen shot then for a second yeah i did
i did
like my heart my heart skipped for a
second though i wanted to do a little
bait and switch
there oh good honestly congratulations
gone your meltdown is the most iconic
moment of the tragedy
hold on 28.5 28.5 percent that's pretty
comfortable relatively close yeah
what was second place second place was
god winning the chess tournament with
24.6 percent wow that was close
oh my god that didn't win
christ i mean i mean yeah it's okay
connor
one one day you'll have your time to
shine yeah hopefully next time well
deserved gone congratulations on your
win yet again
please maybe one day you'll win your own
trip please look forward to more trash
taste specials because they are on their
way
yeah win the next one and we'll get some
more fantastic moments from the special